يأتي هذا في الوقت الذي تواصل فيه الدفاعات الأوكرانية
صد الهجمات الروسية المتعددة.
لدى CNS FR pin قصة
وعلينا أن نحذرك من أن بعض الصور
في تقريره قد تكون
مزعجة، فهو موقع تراه القوات الأوكرانية
في أفيفا في كثير من الأحيان
مدرعة روسية ضخمة.  القوة الهجومية تتجه
نحوهم مباشرة، يتحرك المشاة الروس
دون أي غطاء تقريبًا،
ويطلق الأوكرانيون على هذه الهجمات اسم "اعتداءات اللحوم" لأن
القوات الروسية ليس لديها أي فرصة تقريبًا
للبقاء على قيد الحياة، حيث تطاردهم الطائرات بدون طيار الأوكرانية،
ويهاجمون مع عدد كبير من
الأفراد رئيس وحدة الطائرات بدون طيار
الذي صور مقاطع الفيديو يقول لي اعتداء
بعد اعتداء دون توقف إذا قتلنا 40 إلى
70 منهم بطائرات بدون طيار في يوم واحد، في اليوم التالي
يجددون قواتهم ويواصلون
الهجوم، الأمر مستمر منذ عدة
أشهر حيث يبدو الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين عازمًا على اتخاذ  تعرضت
المركبات الروسية لنيران المدفعية مع
اقترابها من المواقع الأوكرانية، وتناثرت
الأرض
بالجنود الروس القتلى والمحتضرين الذين يحاولون التغلب على
الدفاعات الأوكرانية هنا،
ويقول الأوكرانيون إنهم يصدون معظم
الهجمات لكنهم يفوقونهم تسليحًا
ونقصًا في العدد، ونحن بحاجة إلى المزيد من الناس
المزيد من المعدات العسكرية نحتاج إلى المزيد من
الذخيرة المزيد من الطائرات بدون طيار يقول
لسوء الحظ ليس لدينا الكمية
اللازمة للفوز، نحن بحاجة إلى الكثير
والروس الذين لا يواجهون نفس النقص
يسقطون كميات هائلة من
المراسيم على الأوكرانيين كل شيء
من المدفعية إلى الثقيلة الموجهة
قصف جوي إحدى نقاط الدفاع الرئيسية، وهو
مصنع ضخم لفحم الكوك على حافة المدينة،
حيث يقوم هؤلاء الرجال بإعداد
دفاعاتهم تحت نيران متواصلة من نخبة
القناصين من قوات أوميغا الخاصة الأوكرانية،
وهنا لديهم الغطاء لضرب
الجنود الروس المتقدمين، وغضبهم
واضح.  في السترات التي يرتدونها أثناء
مقابلتنا مع الأسلحة التي لدينا على
مسافات تصل إلى 1300 متر، تصل
فعالية عملنا إلى 90%،
ويقول إنهم يحتاجون إلى هذا النوع من الدقة
للحفاظ على أسلحتهم في
حالة جيدة طوال الوقت الذي
يقولونه في  في البداية، بدا أن
الروس يمكنهم تطويق أيكا
بسرعة كبيرة، كما يقول، ولكن كما نرى، فقد كانت أيكا
ملكنا لمدة 3 أشهر ونحن متمسكون
بالقبض على آيفا في الوقت الحالي حتى مع
هجوم تلو الآخر الذي يأكل
الدفاعات الأوكرانية من أجل plin CNN بالقرب من AA
أوكرانيا